trong lòng cái nhà rồi, cho nên dần nhà thì
sắp sếp là sẽ phải cũng muốn cái loại hình nhà.
Nhà thương mọi,
mọi người 2 có tiền,
thì muốn nhà.
Hãy ở ý của mình,
nhà nước quả ý.
Nhà nước cấp trong những gia đình những người có công bu cách mọi.
Nhưng ở cậu đường những điều kiện,
những nhân tài, những chi thức,
những phần nghệ gì, những người có đón cóp cho đất lợp.
Nhà sẽ đường nhà nước cấp nhà.
Thảo được kiện thức cuộc sống,
cái tục công kiện như thế này.
Nhà trong lý dân được thuy,
thuy dài hạn,
để làm sao công nghiệp những người,
nó đợp trẻ,
để hầu cũng quyền được tức hạn này hạc nữa.
Nhà không đúng nghiệp phá đã quy định,
lý dân có quyền có được chỗ,
có nhà công buộc,
nhà đảm mọi người trong cánh bộ cho con đối,
cho con quan,
cho những người đường thống có nhà công buộc.